Welcome to AERA English TV's Native Maestro.
I am your maitre d' Seita.
And this program is designed to help you become the native maestro.
Alright, today's Maestro Hook.
Maestro Hook is a small conversation piece that you can use with foreigners...
...and it'll make a conversation exciting.
Today's Hook is about comparing yourself to a celebrity.
In Japan, I experience a lot of people comparing somebody to a foreigner...
...and comparing themselves to a celebrity.
Saying, "Oh, you look like so-and-so."...
...or, "Oh, you look like the celebrity, what's-his-name? So-and-so."
And for a foreigner, that's really, really strange.
A lot of times they compare themselves to someone on TV...
We don't really feel comfortable and we don't really know how to react.
It's not like we know the person or it's not like we're related,...
...so the reaction that we always give in a situation like that is,...
..."Um, yeah, thanks and so?"
Even if the person is beautiful or good-looking,...
...it's not so much of a compliment.
So, be careful when you do that...
...'cause in the States, we don't really have that kind of a culture, okay?
Okay, today's Maestro Menu...
You're a spitting image of...
You're a spitting image of your father.
I get that a lot.
Okay, Maestro Line:...
...Wow! I haven't seen you in a long time...
...but you're a spitting image of your mother.
Oh, thanks! I get that a lot.
We really do look alike.
Okay, that's it for today...
...and see you next week again on a new episode of AERA English TV's Native Maestro.
Bye-bye!